well I spend every day at Harvard trying
to help develop the next generation of
leaders and I think there's no shortage
of management talent because you're
short of leadership shortage of
leadership and really sound thinking
leaders who are committed to their
institutions first and put that ahead of
their self-interest it will always put
their institution ahead of their
self-interest I think we've we've
created far too many baby boomers who
are incident in what they can get out of
themselves including a lot of CEOs and I
think we need to get back to a much
longer term perspective and what am i
building back to your word resilience my
job as CEO Medtronic is to build a
resilient institution yes they're going
to be products that don't make it
through the FDA yes they're going to be
quality problems in the future yes
origami government regulation we have to
be resilient enough to adapt to those
and still come out the winter and I
think the financial firms that figure
that out goulburn happens to be one JP
Morgan has to be another those are the
two I'd site is being very resilient to
changes there will be big changes coming
and it is global it's one global economy
one global workforce in one global
market and going back to the layman come
down people say why didn't Paulson and
Bernanke do something they ran out of
time on Sunday because the Asian markets
opened at six o'clock not the next
morning today's ran out of time they
thought they had barkis and so that time
factor it's really a 24-7 world and you
can never escape the markets
because they were thinking about
themselves first and back to my book
seven lessons they weren't facing the
reality that they had caused the
problems they were being too aggressive
ken lewis went went on a limb doing
merrill lynch and getting himself
heavily leveraged and taking some huge
losses and so there were others had
gotten similar problems if Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac leadership as well and I
think problem is that these leaders
thought about how they can gain it in
short term and they weren't really
thinking about building their
institutions a long term and always
having a fallback because they tell you
CEO Medtronic I thought every day what
is our fallback it's going well now but
what happens if I get that phone call
and we've got a huge quality problem er
where are we going to fall back to what
if a major product that we going to
produce three billion in revenues goes
down at the FDA and doesn't get accepted
by them you always have to be thinking
like that Lloyd Blankfein talks about
being paranoid and so does Andy Grove in
and Intel and that's why they're so
effective because they're thinking about
what can go go wrong I don't describe
myself as paranoid but you got to always
be thinking all what can go wrong and
prepare yourself with an escape hatch
that if things if the absolute worst
happens and it comes much worse than you
can imagine you're going to come out of
it you're going to be strong and you're
going to have enough position to go and
invest in the crisis
we're not looking carefully enough at
the selection process they were choosing
people based upon their perception of
their position power and their
aggressiveness are relative to other
people in the firm and they weren't
really looking at the kind of building
type leaders we need the kind of
authentic leaders that are they're
putting the concern of their clients
ahead of their personal concerns they're
putting concern to their employees ahead
of the concern of their shareholders
that they weren't building sustainable
shareholder value that's the goal of any
CEO that only comes from creating better
value for your customers and creating an
employee environment in which people are
highly motivated to do that
I think we did a lot of those leaders
that dive now I've been there to see end
of my six year and I'm very proud of
people I've worked with but yeah I think
we're was too much focus on on finance
and sending to me bill in the financial
community and many too many looking at
what their short-term compensation was
private equity and hedge funds and all
headed that way and a group of my
students last May and these were what
are called George leadership fellows at
Harvard Business School in Kennedy
School created this MBA oath that you're
alluding to that's very parallel to what
you have the Hippocratic oath and
medicine my son the other one of my
son's as a doctor who took that oath
that lawyers take as part of their
admission to the bar gosh I think it's
totally appropriate to put integrity
ahead of all else and I think we lost
sight of that now there's even some
controversy still at the business going
and student body about this but i do
think corporations are chartered by
society and society can lift that
charter or change it and if business is
not recognizing we're doing good for
society if the financial community is
not providing real value for companies
and helping them get financing and
building kind of strong capital markets
we need their solid and keep returning
this kind of volatility it will all be
put in the hands of the power of the
federal government and i don't think
that'd be a healthy thing but that's up
to us to recognize just like Medtronic
has extreme responsibility the patient
reserve Medtronic serves 10 million
patients a year with its products new
patients and if the products aren't
equality or they don't restore me full
life and help the company has failed and
I think each company has that societal
obligation we need to recognize that's
preeminent and only by fulfilling that
that we create sustainable value for our
shareholders we cannot create
shareholder value in the short term on
the backs of society and expect it to be
sustainable